ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW BLOOM.
BURNER* BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHILD.
CAN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP. EIGHT MEN FLORA
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ AS GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US.
ROBERT REAVIS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE.
TEEN VOEPEL --
AND WEBER.
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHA RIVER NEXT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. ONE WEEK AGO TODAY
AT THE MASONIC TEMPLE.
MANY OF US WERE FORTUNATE TO
HEAR REVEREND.
AL SHARPTON SPEAKAT THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS CELEBRATION OF THE LIFE
OF DR MARTIN LUTHER KING.
THAT MORNING REVEREND SHARPTON
CHALLENGED US ALL TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
HE INSPIRED US TO WALK THE WALK
AND NOT JUST TALK THE TALK.
YES HE SAID DON'T JUST CELEBRATE
THE KING BE A KING.
ON AUGUST TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE ON THE STEPS OF THE
LINCOLN MEMORIAL IN WASHINGTON
DC.
DR KING GAVE HIS INSPIRING I
HAVE A DREAM SPEECH.
THE REASON HIS WORDS CONTINUE TO
RESONATE WITHIN THE HEARTS OF
PEOPLE EVERYWHERE.
IS BECAUSE THE DREAM THAT HE
SPOKE OF THAT DAY.
IS THE DREAM THAT LIVES IN THE
HEART OF ALL HUMANITY.
IT IS A DREAM FOR ALL PEOPLE
EVERYWHERE TO LIVE TOGETHER WITH
HUMAN KINDNESS AND EMPATHY.
A FIRM THE AUGUST DAY IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE DOCTOR
KING'S WORDS CONTINUE TO AWAKEN
PEOPLE EVERYWHERE.
THE DREAM THAT LIVES DEEP.
DEEP WITHIN ALL OF OUR HEARTS.
IS A DREAM UPON WHICH AMERICA
WAS FOUNDED.
IS DR KING SAID OVER FIFTY FIVE
YEARS AGO.
I STILL HAVE A DREAM.
IT IS A DREAM DEEPLY ROOTED IN
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
I HAVE A DREAM THAT ONE DAY THIS
NATION WILL RISE UP.
AND LIVE OUT THE TRUE MEANING OF
ITS CREED.
WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE SELF
EVIDENT.
THAT ALL MEN ARE CREATED EQUAL.
LET US KEEP THIS DREAM ALIVE SO
IN MY CONTINUE TO RESONATE. FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME.
NAM WOMAN UP SOON WHAT KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS PLEASE
RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR HEART.
BEGIN.
I PLEDGE. TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
TUESDAY JANUARY EIGHTH TWENTY
NINETEEN ASSEMBLY MET AT SEVEN
AM HONORABLE CECILIA
AGUIAR-CURRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOURTH DISTRICT RESIDING GP
DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK.
READING CLICK KATHLEEN LOOTED
LOUIS READING THE ONLY PLACE IN
THE MORNING ROLL CALL
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BURNER FOR BATH BONTA.
ALL THEN MOVES AND MISTER LACKEY
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
BE DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS.
IN PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND OF BILLS WILL
BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE --
ARE.
NINE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATRICK
O'DONNELL.
IN FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN DALLY.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARIE
WALDRON
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO MR
MAYES MISTER MAYES HAS GAS IN
THE CHAMBER TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
MEMBERS IN THE LEADER'S CHARTER
SCHOOL IS A KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
EIGHTH GRADE SCHOOL FOUNDED IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE HEART OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IN THE CITY OF YUCAIPA.
THEIR PURPOSE IS TO INSPIRE A
NEW GENERATION OF STUDENTS
TRAINED TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE WITH
HONESTY INTEGRITY IN SERVICE
WHILE HOLDING TO HIGH.
STANDARDS FOR ALL.
I AM PROUD AND HONORED TO
WELCOME WELCOME THEM IN THE
GALLERY IF YOU GUYS WILL STAND
UP.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM
WELCOME. TO THE SEVENTH AND
EIGHTH GRADERS FROM IN THE
LEADER'S CHARTER SCHOOL
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER MISTER MCCARTY.
MR MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YOUR GUESS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING STUDENTS IN
THE GALLERY FROM CENTER HIGH
SCHOOL IN MY DISTRICT AND COLUSA
HIGH SCHOOL FROM JUST NORTH OF
HERE.
THEY ARE PART OF THE FUTURE
BUSINESS LEADERS OF AMERICA HERE
TO LEARN ABOUT OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS IN GOVERNMENT AWARENESS.
AGAIN WELCOME TO OUR STATE
CAPITOL AND PLEASE WELCOME OUR
GUESTS THANK YOU.
AND MR LEVINE YOU HAVE GUESTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY WE'VE GOT
THIRTY FIVE ELEVENTH AND TWELFTH
GRADERS FROM SAN ANSELMO SIR
FRANCIS DRAKE HIGH SCHOOL
JOINING US GO PIRATES.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM
TO THE CAPITAL
GALLERY MS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M HONORED TO INTRODUCE
A SPECIAL GROUP HERE TODAY FROM
UP IN THE GALLERY.
WE HAVE TWENTY EIGHT FOURTH
GRADERS VISITING US FROM BIRCH
LANE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN DAVIS.
THIS IS MRS LONGS CLASS AND
THEY'RE ALL HERE TO TAKE A LOOK
AROUND AND SEE WHAT WE DO SO
EVERYBODY WELCOME THEM.
GIVE A WARM ASSEMBLY WELCOME
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE.
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AC ARE NINE THE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINE BY FAMILY MEMBER KALRA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO INDIA
REPUBLIC DAY.
MISTER KALRA ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
OF IT'S MY HONOR. TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINE RECOGNIZING THE HISTORICAL
SIGNIFICANCE OF INDIA REPUBLIC
DAY.
OF THE HERITAGE OF CONTRIBUTIONS
OF INDIAN AMERICANS. TO THIS
STATE.
AB THE INDIAN CONSTITUTION
SIMILARLY TO OURS BEGINS WITH WE
THE PEOPLE [inaudible]
OF INDIA.
HAVING SOLEMNLY RESOLVED. TO
CONSTITUTE INDIA INTO A
SOVEREIGN DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC.
AND TO SECURE TO ALL ITS
CITIZENS JUSTICE.
SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND POLITICAL.
LIBERTY OF THOUGHT EXPRESSION
BELIEVE FAITH AND WORSHIP.
THE QUALITY OF STATUS AN
OPPORTUNITY.
CENTRO PROMOTE AMONG THE MALL
FRATERNITY.
ASSURING THE DIGNITY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL.
AND THE UNITY.
OF THE NATION.
INDIA'S REPUBLIC K. REFERS TO
THE DAY INDIA'S CONSTITUTION WAS
ADOPTED IN NINETEEN FIFTY ON
JANUARY.
TWENTY SIX WHICH GAVE THE
CITIZENS OF INDIA THE POWER TO
CHOOSE THEIR OWN GOVERNMENT.
AND PAVE THE WAY FOR THE LARGEST
DEMOCRACY IN THE WORLD.
ALTHOUGH INDIA PROCLAIMED ITS
INDEPENDENCE AUGUST FIFTEENTH
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN FALLING
DIACHRONIC MOVEMENT OF
NONVIOLENT RESISTANCE AND CIVIL.
DISOBEDIENCE LED BY MAHATMA
GANDHI.
IT A NOT YET HAVE A PERMANENT.
CONSTITUTION.
IN DECEMBER AS THE FIRST INDIAN
AMERICAN.
AND HISTORY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE.
I WAS HONORED TO LEAD ASSEMBLY
DELEGATION ON BEHALF OF SPEAKER
RENDON. TO INDIA DURING THE
INTERIM BUT THE NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO FURTHER BUILD.
OUR STATE'S TIES WITH INDIA
LEARN FROM EACH OTHER YOUR NINE
ALSO OFFERS THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
REFLECT ON THE MANY CHEAP MINTS.
AND CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE INDIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE IN THIS
GREAT STATE.
TODAY INDIA IS THE WORLD'S
LARGEST DEMOCRACY AND SHARES A
COMMITMENT TO THE BASIC
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES OF
FREEDOM OPPORTUNITY AND JUSTICE.
WITH OUR COUNTRY.
ALTHOUGH LIKE US THEY'RE NOT
PERFECT.
THEY TO CONTINUE ON THEIR
JOURNEY TO FORM A MORE PERFECT
UNION.
AND WITH THAT MISTER SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR AN AYE
VOTE FOR ACR.
NINE AND AT THE TIME --
THE PROPER TIME REQUEST THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA MS GARCIA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT AS A CO
AUTHOR OF A C. R..
NINE BETWEEN JANUARY TWENTY
SIXTH AS AS INDIA REPUBLIC DAY.
ENERGY ALL CALIFORNIANS WHO
JOINED IN CELEBRATING.
IN MY DISTRICT THE HAVE THE CITY
OF OUR TEAS ARE ALSO KNOWN AS
LITTLE INDIA.
OUR WE HAVE AMERICAN INDIAN
CULTURES COME TOGETHER AND IT'S
A BEAUTIFUL TAPESTRY OF HOW
CULTURES COME TOGETHER NOW WE
ARE BETTER COMMUNITY FOR THAT.
THE TODAY I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE COMMEMORATE AND
CELEBRATE --
THIS CULTURE IN MY BACKYARD.
OUR AUTHOR FROM SAN JOSE.
AT LET US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
HISTORY OF THIS AND AND THAT BY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PEOPLE HAD
A REPUBLIC IN A CONSTITUTION
THAT REFLECTED THEIR WISHES.
IT'S THE GOVERNMENT OF THE
PEOPLE BY THE PEOPLE IF THEY
BELIEVE THAT THE PEOPLE OF BOTH
INDIA AND THE UNITED STATES
UNDERSTAND ALL TOO WELL.
AS THE WOMEN IT MAKES ME PROUD
THAT INDIA HAD ITS FIRST FEMALE
PRIME MINISTER BACK IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX WITHIN THEIR OF
BONDING.
CAESAR THIS PRIME MINISTER FROM
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX EVENT.
AND THEN AGAIN IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY AND TELL HER
ASSASSINATION IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR SHE'S A
SECOND LONGEST SERVING PRIME
MINISTER OF INDIA.
DEMOCRACY IS A NEVER ENDING
JOURNEY THAT REQUIRES ALL OF US
TO KEEP WORKING AT IT AND TO
KEEP MOVING FORWARD.
IT ALSO REMINDS US OF OUR TRULY
RICH WE ARE HEARING CALIFORNIA.
EVERY CELEBRATION OVER THE
RECEIVE OF LIKE AN ACTIVE
ASSISTANCE AND IT GIVES ME HOPE.
THEIR HISTORY AND CULTURE AS
WITH THE MANY CULTURES THAT HAVE
DECIDED TO CALL THE STATE THEIR
HOME.
ONLY MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE
VIBRANT AND COLORFUL PLACE TO
LIVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
NAME IS GARCIA [inaudible]
MS BAUER-KAHAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IS A PROUD PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR.
TO A C. R. NINE IN RECOGNIZING
JANUARY TWENTY SIXTH AS INDIA
REPUBLIC DAY HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS A DIVERSE STATE
WITH MANY THE CLAIM HERITAGE AND
IDENTITY TO THE COUNTRY OF INDIA.
WHICH SHARES A COMMITMENT TO THE
BASIC FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES OF
FREEDOM OPPORTUNITY AND JUSTICE
THROUGH DEMOCRACY.
I JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
JOSE IN SUPPORT OF INDIA
REPUBLIC DAY AND ON BEHALF OF
THE INDIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
I REPRESENT.
AND TO CELEBRATE THEIR VAST
CONTRIBUTION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MR CHIU KANSEN CHU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SAN
COLLEAGUES ARE I SAYS THE PRINCE
VOCAL AUTHOR OF AC R. NIGHT AND
JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE.
TO CELEBRATE THE INDIAN A
REPUBLIC DAY I'M PROUD TO
REPRESENT A VERY DIVERSE --
DISTRICT WHERE WE CELEBRATE ALL
CULTURES TRADITIONS AND HOLIDAYS
FROM ALL ACROSS THE WORLD.
AS WE CELEBRATE THE LARGEST
REPUBLIC IN THE OLDEST REPUBLIC
WE ARE REMINDED OF HIS STRUGGLES
AND SACRIFICE OF MANY FREEDOM
FIGHTERS. TO MAY TO HAVE DEAR
INDEPENDENCE AND ALSO I WILL
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
THE INDO AMERICANS.
THEIR VALUE VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTION MAY THROUGH ALL THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE U. S. MY
DISTRICT HAS A VERY RICH READ
INDIAN COMMUNITY.
AND THERE'S ALWAYS A JOY FOR ME
TO BE ABLE TO CELEBRATE THE
STATE WITH MY CONSTITUENTS THANK
YOU IT AND I URGE FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS YOU MISS RAY S..
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN.
SUPPORT OF A C. R. NINE
RECOGNIZING JANUARY TWENTY SIX
AS INDIA REPUBLIC DAY.
THIS RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES THE
DETERMINATION OF THE INDIAN
PEOPLE AND GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON THE
JOURNEY TO ESTABLISH A SOVEREIGN
DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC.
IT ALSO ALLOWS US TO APPRECIATE
THE STATUS OF THEIR DEMOCRACY.
THE INDIAN CONSTITUTION
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PRINCIPLES OF A JUST
SOCIETY.
LIBERTY EQUALITY AND COMMUNITY.
AND YOU ALSO HOUSING EXTREMELY
ENGAGED ELECTORATE WITH VOTER
TURNOUT OF OVER 70% DURING THE
LAST ELECTION IN THE COUNTRY OF
OVER ONE POINT THREE BILLION.
THIS SHOULD BE A GOAL OF VOTER
PARTICIPATION THAT WE SHOULD
STRIVE TO ACHIEVE HERE AND
ACROSS THE U. S..
WHERE THIS LAST CYCLE?
TURNOUT WAS STILL BELOW 50%.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF ASIAN
INDIANS IN THE UNITED STATES AND
THEY SEE ARE NINE RECOGNIZES
THEM AS WELL.
AS THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THEIR
PEOPLE.
THIS LAST DECEMBER I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE TO BE A PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA DELEGATION TO INDIA
LED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
OUR FIRST.
INDIAN AMERICAN EVER TO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE.
THE TRIP WAS INCREDIBLE.
WHETHER WE WERE LEARNING ABOUT
BUSINESS INCUBATOR SUPPORTING
LOCAL ENTREPRENEURS ARE MEETING
THE PUT JABI SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE.
WE WERE ALWAYS TREATED WITH
WORLD CLASS HOSPITALITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS REYES.
SEEING THE ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION MISTER KALRA
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A THANK
YOU TO ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR
YOUR VERY KIND WORDS AND
RESPECTED WELL WISHES FOR THE
INDIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
ASPECT THE ASPIRIN I BOWED AND
AS OF THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THIS CALL WAS ASKED HIM THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
THE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
THERE SEVENTY FIVE CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THERE WILL BE A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE LOUNGE
UPON A GERMAN OF SESSION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
IN THE LOUNGE UPON ADJOURNMENTS.
OTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH NO FLOOR
SESSION --
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH FLOOR SESSION IS
AT TWELVE FORTY FIVE PLEASE NOTE
THE TIME. TWELVE FORTY FIVE
FLOOR SESSION.
ON MONDAY ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
FLORA SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY JANUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH AT TWELVE FORTY FIVE PM
IN THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED